moi je suis embêté
ensuite je suis embêté ça fait deux fois
que je me fais escroquer
mais oui parce que l'autre fois j'avais
été allé plus à Paris oui j'avais été
faire des courses je cherche des
antiquités et alors pour ma belle-mère
j'avais décidé de lui offrir un vase moi
je suis embêté parce que c'est une
escroquerie savez-vous regarder
c'est un vase à la con ça on peut pas
mettre de fleurs ils ont pas mis
alors j'arrive sur le terrain comme ceci
on dessine par terre le plan de la
maison je disais vous mettez l'entrée et
si vous mettez la cuisine et si vous
mettez le salon là vous mettez un salon
de télévision l'escalier puis les quatre
chambres en l'air
d'une chose est importante c'est qu'ici
dans l'entrée je veux un aloya
c'est important la loyers toute la
classe d'une maison tu peux me dire oui
oui pas de problème donc je suis venu un
mois plus tard ils avaient commencé les
fondations moi j'ai regardé comme
c'était sur les planches j'étais très
content je dis surtout vous oubliez pas
de me mettre un haloïa dans l'entrée
c'est tout ce qui donne la vie dans une
maison hein pas de problème mais je
sentais bien qu'il y avait quand même
quelque chose qui passait pas il se
disait mais qu'est-ce que c'est ça
6 mois plus tard j'ai pris livraison de
la maison
alors je vais bien la cuisine l'entrée
le living room le salon de télévision
l'escalier les quatre chambres mais dans
l'entrée
le promoteur je le dis mais la maison
est parfaite mais il y a pas la noyau
il me dit mais dans la cuisine j'ai dit
dans la cuisine
moi j'ai demandé un an et demi
c'est Mohamed
il a décidé de rentrer dans l'armée
française
de votre côté s'il vous plaît je
voudrais rentrer de votre côté l'armée
faire la guerre s'il vous plaît
pas de problème
est-ce que tu as déjà fait du vélo j'ai
fait toute l'année du vélo
que tu as déjà fait de la photo des
photos toute la journée je la fais les
photos clique claques à la maison
fait du parachutiste des parachutistes
avec le sac à dos qui chauffent la
poignée le champignon il sauve voilà
écoute c'est ça demain matin tu viens un
avion va prendre il te décolle il va te
prendre il décolle
un avion d'école il te prend quand la
lumière clignote tu sautes tu ouvres ton
parachute tu prends le vélo qui est en
bas tu vas faire des photos des kiboutes
et tu reviens nous dire ce que tu as vu
j'ai tout compris je dois prendre le
vélo je fais les photos et je te dis que
tout ce que c'est
devant le parachute de rien il a
l'altimètre qui a qu'une aiguille il a
cru que c'était la tenteuse les deux
autres étaient en option
la lumière vertic clignote le pilote il
fait chaud quoi
j'ai chauffé un petit mec je les vois
que c'est le moment je prends la poignée
je bouffe j'ouvre le parachute la
de parachute
j'ai des parachute derrière je prends la
poignée derrière je boum j'ouvre le
parasite des yeux parachute voilà
du matériel français je suis sûr quand
j'arrive en bas le vélo il est crevé
c'est une histoire qui se passe en
Écosse pour les amis golfeurs nous
sommes sur le golfe de Sainte-Foy blues
en école et nous sommes sur le parcours
du 18 juin et nous sommes sur le fameux
trou du numéro 7 il y a la un vieux
joueur de golf un vieux joueur de Call
anglais british avec la chaussure avec
le petit pompon il y a le pantalon de
tuile la chemise de cashfire la cravate
il est ici sur l'outil avec son drive
tu prends un drive tu arrives sur le
titre il fait un swing qui tombe sur le
green et on deux fois tu fais le pas
avant faut apprendre l'anglais
donc il est là le club à la main
la position est importante
il vise le green
il fait un swing mon ami et la balle qui
décolle qui décolle qui monte qui monte
malheureusement un courant d'air déplace
la balle et la balle tombe dans le rouge
[Rires]
donc il prend son caddie et part à la
recherche de son bord
du dimanche
que le vieux précédent
la balle là-bas elle est le temps et
elle atterrit en plein sur le
sur le bas du dos du vieux joueur qui
était en train de chercher sa balle à ce
moment-là le mec se relève est fait
écouter cher Monsieur apprenez que
généralement au golf dans le trou que
l'on vise il y a un drapeau
et le 7 vanderpen qui arrive parfois le
disait alors ils vont à l'école de ski
il fait bonjour ma femme et moi nous
désirerions avoir le même moniteur que
l'année dernière c'était à monétaire
super ça une pédagogie d'enfer pour que
c'est tout petit
le prénom matos
avec un peu de rouge oui malgré sur le
pull rouge il avait une médaille oui
mais ils ont tous la médaille
il avait un défaut anatomique c'est à
dire on a entendu dire qu'il avait
[Rires]
il avait deux anus
deux anus bah oui parce que quand on
était dans la queue du tire-fesse
souvent des collègues arrivaient à lui
les regarder il lui disait alors comment
tu t'en sors avec tes deux trous du cul
c'est une histoire qui se passe dans le
sud de la France pas exactement à
Marseille mais sur la droite de
Marseille quand on descend la Canebière
et qu'on longe de vieux port on arrive
dans les calanques et là il y a un petit
village qui s'appelle l'Estaque et les
stars que l'époque que je vous cause ce
bled il y avait genre 800 800 habitants
de bistrots
qu'il habite à l'Estaque il est jamais
sorti de l'Estaque et un jour il décide
d'aller visiter le monde à la retraite
il a touché le chèque il prend la valise
les économies il arrive sur le perron de
la maison et là il s'est dit où je vais
et où je vais y retourne à la maison sur
le MAP sur le piano il y avait une
marque monde il prend la mappemonde
[Musique]
il arrive à la gare de l'Estaque
bonjour je voudrais bien de train pour
piquer
comment
quelque chose
bonjour je voudrais bien pour péter
et qu'est-ce que c'est ça
il arrive à la gare de Lyon bonjour je
voudrais bien de faire pour piquer
ça
pour la gare de Moscou et tu reprends
nos enfants étaient la sardines
longtemps les Bartas de la race ta
blague tu nous fais de l'ombre à part ça
Momo
bonjour je voudrais vous péter s'il vous
plaît
passeport le mec on lui fait son
visa Lupi le billet de train il arrive à
Pékin enfin il visite pk en long en
large en travers en hauteur en diagonale
en profondeur au bout de 8 jours Pékin
basta et il suffit de rentrer à la
maison il arrive à la gare de Pékin
bonjour
excusez-moi de vous déranger
je voudrais bien le train pour l'Estaque
à ce moment-là le méga
l'autre jour je rentre chez moi je mets
la clé dans la serrure et au moment où
j'ouvre la porte
j'entends une voix qui fait
la voix
le plus cher non plus
alors je me retourne
je rentre dans la maison au moment où
j'ai pour fermer la porte j'entends la
voix qui insiste qui fait
et sur la rampe du perron de la maison
il y avait une grenouille
dans la grenouille
elle est là comme ça
[Rires]
elle fait beaucoup et elle saute sur le
péron et elle rentre dans l'entrée de la
maison j'ai fait bête jeune pas
elle me dit
oui on est chez moi il me dit
je vous fais visiter
[Rires]
la salle à manger la cuisine mon bureau
et l'escalier qui mène au champ et me
dit
[Rires]
je monte je fais quelque part elle
arrive au premier étage elle me dit
et là c'est ma chambre j'ouvre la porte
en deux mots elle était sur le lit elle
se retourne elle se met sur l'oreiller
sur le dos et elle me dit
toi
et elle insiste elle me dit
alors il y a un moment je me dis attends
et ben j'y vais et c'est au moment où je
l'ai embrassé qu'elle s'est transformée
en petite fille monsieur le juge
c'est un mec qui arrive dans une banque
qui fait salut la grosse de
compte dans ta banque de merde
[Rires]
pardon les jours de la gueule je
vais ouvrir un de compte dans ta
bande de merde je te dis la grosse
monsieur je vous prierai de châtier
votre langage un petit peu dans une
banque il manque de bonne société les
gens avec un minimum d'éducation un
pompier
grosse merde
écoutez je vais chercher le
directeur le directeur qui arrive
monsieur a un problème et les gens ont
un problème il y a un avion qui est
m'empêche d'ouvrir un de compte
dans ce monde de merde
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de parler
comme ça qui me permet c'est que je ne
gagne au loto j'ai 3 milliards à placés
ah et c'est cette conne qui vous embête
cet accord pour terminer cet accord une
histoire qui se passe dans le sud de la
France et
pour bien vous mettre dans le contexte
de cette histoire elle le touche la
Marine nationale puisque l'histoire se
passe sur le porte-avion Clémenceau
sur le porte-avion Clemenceau il y a
3000 marins du sexe masculin qui vient
de passer six mois complet en mer
ça fait 6 mois que sur ce de bout
de ferraille à 3000 gosses qui attend
depuis une chose c'est la permission le
bateau rentre en rade de Toulon les
remorqueurs le remords les
poussent afin de bateau il paie un
créneau
on remet le bateau en étant on replie
les ailes des avions on descend les
avions dans la soute on nettoie la
carrée on nettoie le pont les marins
montent avec le paquetage sur l'épaule
un salut à la coupée on descend la
passerelle et sur le quai du port on
retrouve les familles qui sont venus
attendre les palais les marins les
parents les cousins les cousines les
tendent les ondes ou les fiancés tout le
monde est là en une demi-heure toutes
les familles récupèrent les marins et
ils restent de part et d'autre dans la
passerelle deux couillons que des gays
est venu les attaques ils sont tout seul
la dernière fois qu'on est parti
ensemble on a pris un bide monumental
alors toi tu parles de ton côté moi je
pars de mon côté demain matin on se
retrouve
d'accord il part chacun de leur côté
lendemain matin il se retrouve alors
Christian
et tout
j'arrive dans un bar Chez zézette pas
fermé la porte du bar de gonzesse et le
tombeau dessus je te remonte dans la
chambre de l'hôtel
je fume une petite cigarette je vais
prendre une petite douche j'arrive dans
un autre bar Chez lourdes
j'ai pas fermé la porte du bar pas de
chef de compte 3 Go dessus les trois
gonzesses dans la chambre de l'hôtel
allez charter
3 et 2 sec pendant que c'est une nuit
d'enfer j'en peux plus je les ai on
dirait des raisins de correct
et toi
moi il m'est arrivé une galère
j'ai pas tout compris
le pompon rouge Marine nationale
Clémenceau et tout j'arrive dans un bar
que déjà j'aurais dû me méfier le nom du
bar
les réformés
je rentre dans le bas j'ai pas fermé la
porte du Barça d'accord passé pas deux
pas quatre pas trois une deuxième c'est
le me tombe dessus elle me saute au cou
et elle me dit texto recto verso route
toi biche je vais te montrer comment
j'aime les marais parce que je fais
l'amour
j'ai dit attends tu me fais retour en
arrière avec arrêt sur l'image je te
donne tu vas y aller toute seule hein
je vais te montrer comment
j'aime les marais je fais l'amour
tempête je me suis dit ouais l'amour oui
la tempête oui tu as les deux ensemble
ça fait deux ans
on arrive chez elle elle avait une
invité à table dans un repas de famille
que tu as envie d'aller au collège je
suis tendresse à l'atelier et tu dis
pardon excusez-moi de vous déranger
saurais-je caresser l'espoir de vous
voir sonner afin que quelqu'un puisse
venir m'indiquer le chemin des
commodités
ça fait longtemps
alors après le café elle me met dans sa
chambre
elle se déshabille
il était midi pétard
[Applaudissements]
tu me files
tu viens à côté de lui tu t'as genoux et
tu prends le sommet avec des domaines et
tu le remue très fort
je vais te faire des creux de 4 mètres
j'ai fait quoi avec la lumière j'ai
hôpitaux j'allume mais j'étais
comment discuter froid super reçu le
aussi
des pouces dessus
mais alors finalement tu l'as indiqué ou
pas mais tu es fou l'homme le temps
qu'il faisait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]